Let's zoom in here a little bit. We know that 95% of sample means will be within
two standard deviations from the mean. Most likely, this sample mean here is one
of the 95% that will fall within two standard deviations of the new sampling
distribution, if everyone used the Bieber Tweeter. So, in other words we have
this new predicted population mean. We'll call it mu sub BT for Bieber Tweeter.
Our best guess for this is 40, but it'll be within an interval around 40, most
likely. And we know that 95% of sample means, just of people who use the Beaver
Tweeter, will be within this interval. Well, most likely, this is one of those
95%. Let's assume that this is in that interval. If this sample mean is indeed
within this interval, then what could the population mean be? Well, if 40 is in
this interval, we know 40 has to be greater than this but smaller than this. Do
you remember how to solve inequalities like this? So, we're trying to solve for
the population mean. So, let's subtract it from all three sides of this
inequality. If we do that, then these cancel and these cancel. So, we're left
with negative 2 times the standard error is less than 40 minus the population
mean is less than positive 2 times the standard error. Now, I'll subtract 40
from all three sides of the equation. So, here, we get negative 40. And now, the
last thing we need to do is to make this positive. So, we'll multiply by
negative one on all 3 sides. When we multiply or divide by a negative number,
these inequalities go the opposite way. When we multiply this by negative one,
we get positive 40 plus 2 times sigma over root n is greater than positive
population mean is greater than positive 40 minus 2 times the standard error.
And now, we have this gorgeous interval. So, let's recap really quick. We know
that 95% of sample means will fall within two standard errors of the population
mean. We're guessing that the sample mean we have is one of those 95% that falls
within this interval. And if that's the case, we're pretty sure that the
population mean, then is between this sample mean plus or minus 2 times the
standard error.